hi there I'm an oppressor Robinson for  gamespot here on the frontline at San  Diego comic-con 2014 as you can see I am  standing in the much-anticipated  Assassin's Creed unity obstacle course  now parkour is one of those things that  I have never possessed skills in but  I've always wanted to do so I'm going to  channel my inner assassin and try to get  the best time possible in this obstacle  course  what  there's so much going on at the  Assassin's Creed unity booth and so many  people showing their comic-con spirit in  cosplay lots of parkour amazing  assassins all sorts of other characters  and even Casey from American Ninja  Warrior let me know if you stopped by  and what you thought tweet at Anna  Prosser